euh bienvenue dans le grand froid sept
dollars et 23
cents pas si tu me donnes un pourboire je dois vraiment chanter
ensemble comme
un double scoop bien
tu veux que je sois à la maison après le travail parfait c'est
un rendez-vous ce n'est pas un rendez-vous cela ressemble
à un jour
alors samedi ici je viendrai te chercher à
sept heures c'est un rendez-vous d'accord pour une
fois
est-ce que cette fille a un nom isabelle un de
plus
un de plus moi et mon père nous essayons de
formuler un plan
honorer la société piste du conseil étudiant bla
bla bla c'est ce que tu veux vraiment
mais
viens avec moi whoa ça s'appelle mon boof
de preuve
laisse moi voir quoi  tu as non je ne rappe pas
mec tu perds du temps à plus
tard je suis désolé mec
regarde juste parce que je sais ce que je veux
ne veut pas dire que je l'obtiens toujours mais au
moins je suis honnête avec moi-même
que faire  tu veux je veux te sortir à
nouveau les
gens font des choses quand ils sortent avec moi je
ne sors pas avec darren yo  tu vas devoir
partir est-
ce que tu es même comme moi ce n'est pas si simple
partout où je regarde je te vois je suis juste en
train de courir après quelque chose
j'ai un an à vivre si cette vie
continue ça bouge comme un manège
non  ce n'est pas toujours facile mais rien ne l'est jamais
c'est pourquoi nous faisons des plans d'accord fille
fuyons j'ai un plan izzy nous
allons vivre toute notre vie tous les
jalons de cette année
toi et moi partons darren je ne
crois pas  dans les fins heureuses
crois en moi une condition
tout ce que tu dois arrêter de dire je t'aime
Musique]
la seule façon d'apprendre la vie est de
vivre et j'ai appris que chaque
instant
est votre moment si vous parvenez à regarder au-
delà de vos propres peurs et des attentes des autres,
la récompense est votre vie
vous